do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training now
brothers and sisters
today I'm in Buffalo your team's house
thank you for inviting me to your house
I really appreciate it
and as you guys might know brothers and
sisters there was some allegations
pertaining to for example Angel culture
Angel tools and travels yes Andrew tours
and troubles
um which was that there was a video
going by I think somebody was driving
past the temple
um is that in England it's on Ealing
Road it's an ailing world so basically a
Muslim was driving past and he saw the
coach and obviously there's speculation
because as you might know
um a a group of people of um who are
supporting the BJP the IRS is the hindut
group there was three to four hundred of
them who went to Leicester and
um they were marching through chanting
and they had weapons obviously they were
provoking the Muslim Community
and obviously the Muslims are rightfully
upset about this because it was very
random because things did calm down
um and obviously the Muslim Community
are very upset because people are scared
to take their kids outside that's what's
going to happen and some Muslims will
hospitalized some were stabbed
um so they were very angry which is
understandable but as Muslims and Islam
our religion teaches us basic things
which is uh that Justice is very
important to us to be just to even if
it's our enemy which Allah Allah and God
Almighty in the Quran tells us to be
upholders of Justice even if it's
against yourself even if it's against my
mom my dad yes if they are wrong let's
see you're my mother you're my father I
love you but you are wrong here so it's
very important for us to be just so
there was allegations going
um around that your coaches were the
coaches that these hindutra RSS BJP
group used to transport these
individuals these these individual
belongings extreme group to Leicester so
I'll ask you very directly was you
involved in this did you was it your
coaches that carried the these group and
these individuals to Leicester
but if we were never involved and my
coaches never came to Leicester since
two months
okay
my we do day trips
uh mostly seasoned okay like ilo5 turtle
door Bournemouth we do Scotland
last weekend yeah
the coach which was parked outside
Temple yes Saturday morning it went Isle
of Wight for a whole day trip
okay so whole day it was in Iowa fight
now as you know idle fight you have to
use the fairy yes yes so even Ferry
company has all the record CCTV is
everything that that coach was all day
in ILO fight
when it came back from Isle of white on
the way back we had some small technical
issue in a coach so buzzer was going on
when driver was driving yeah
so it came wemly around 9 30
now outside Temple there is a proper
layby where you can park your coach yeah
so I was in Scotland so when driver told
me that this thing is going on and his
driving I was supposed to finish as well
so I said look just park the coach there
I will tell my mechanic he will come and
have a look yeah I know it's uh late
night but because that coach need to go
next day that's been Sunday morning to
durdle door and okay because that's our
Sunday job which same coach need to
cover but because of technical issue we
decided to park that coach same place
now we call our mechanic and he came as
well he checked the coach he removed
that fault with computer yeah
and Coach stayed whole night at the same
place okay Saturday night okay
Sunday early morning my another driver
one of my friends who drive for us yeah
he took the coach yeah to dadel room
Bournemouth okay
so that's what that coach did Saturday
and Sunday okay but you do have more
than one coach how many coaches we have
four coaches okay so someone might say
that what about your other free coaches
yes now I will tell you yes please uh
first thing I have four coach or uh
coaches are with uh fitted with the
tracker yes now
my burgundy color coach yeah I took
myself to Scotland for three days okay
Saturday Sunday Monday yes I came back
Monday night with the same coach okay
all the evidence are there yeah and do
not forget coaches never went empty it's
always with customers passenger yes so
we have so many people who knows that
they were inside the coach and Coach
took them for roam around and
sightseeing yeah okay so that that's one
coach which I took to the Scotland yes a
second coach
Friday night
60 people we pick up from ilford
out from outside the gurudwara all the
Punjabi people okay okay
old and we took everyone that coach took
everyone to mahakali Temple in his Wells
yes so coach reached around half past
four Saturday early morning yeah and it
departed in the evening
uh from four o'clock something from
there yeah so that coach went back
straight to that gurudwara dropped the
people coach came back to Wembley yes
because we have the same job Saturday
night yes going again back to Temple
okay so it came to eling Road uh empty
because he dropped everyone in ilford
yeah and he pick up another 60 no uh
that Night 40 passenger something or 44
passenger yeah and that went to straight
to Wells Temple okay settle in it okay
okay so that that was the second
question now that's a 61 seater okay now
third coach which is a white color coach
okay
white Coach the third coach Saturday I
will tell you where it went it went
deadly Bournemouth okay
that coach came yeah okay and uh that
coach
came uh here sanatan Temple again 9 30
at night and that coach uh yeah then it
went to drop people at ilford Islam same
coach came back to illing Road 12
o'clock at night Saturday night 12
o'clock yes and went Temple so Saturday
night two coaches went to Temple
mahakali Temple in South Wales Okay so
that two coaches all the cctvs are there
M4 because it's where all the way up to
kamarthan 220 miles okay the whole M4
Motorway the services wherever it stops
yes so two coaches are there okay blue
coach was already parked on the road yes
and fourth I was in Scotland yes
now the blue coach which they show in a
video yes because it was just parked
outside the temple there and unlucky
Temple was next to the coach yeah
someone took the picture and met the
whole story yes that coach came back
from Leicester yes
what what I am saying is okay you have
seen that video that coach is parked
yeah obviously because we live in
Wembley our pickup point is there okay
so which can be there yes I was gonna
say why why is your coaches no no I'm
just curious so people are saying is
connected to the temple uh which again
it's not an issue it's it's our issue is
not pertaining to the temple or the
Hindus and the religious it's gonna have
to do that
um it's it's just that basically they're
asking for example
um is is your company registered to the
temple no no because we have nothing to
do with temple so it's your pickup point
you say it's just to pick a point for
for how long have you been there since
2009 okay yes so because when I started
I was completely new in this industry
yeah and I had no idea like because we
have no office where to keep the pickup
point then I thought okay because
everyone goes to Temple people know
exactly where Temple is let's tell
everyone that come outside Temple it's
very easy yes and there is a big layby
yeah you know the parking space where
you can stop your coach yes that's the
only reason since 2009 yeah we are using
our pickup Point outside Temple yeah so
your your company is not there's another
misconception that is your company
registered into that time no at all
if anyone has a doubt please check
company House website yeah they will get
all the information so and it won't be
in the term for you no way definitely
not because we have nothing to do with
the temple yes this is my own company
yes
I understand okay so now the thing is
that that's clarified and I think that's
very important and I don't think there
is any sufficient evidence just because
somebody's driving past the temple and
they see your coach to make a
correlation I think would be unfair I
understand that
um and I hope that's clarified
um so from your point of view there's
some pictures that that were taken I
don't know if you're in them or not with
a bjb BJP flank you are 100 right yes so
now the thing is just just to clarify
that because what BJP are the bjprss
group in India this is not an issue
where they have a problem with the
Muslims they have a problem with their
Sikhs and the Christians and other
minorities and that's happening and
there's a lot of back and forth
happening with people being killed uh
you know mosques being burned be it
Christians being attacked or Sikhs and
even in uh less time it was a sick man
who was beaten as well so the thing is
when they see that because obviously I
think that's where the connections
happening you had a picture with this
flag and what's your take on it number
one with the picture number two do you
condemn the BJP the RSS group what
they're doing in India and what happened
in Leicester like what is you how do you
feel about that okay let us talk about
picture first yes yeah now
see Corona how you know that in Corona
coach industry suffered a lot yes
government never helped to coach
industry lots of companies shut down
okay well how you will pay your
installment yeah my one coach yeah I'm
paying four thousand pound a month
installment okay I just bought it before
Corona I lost around 127 000 pound loss
okay now when you are doing nothing and
if someone hire your coach yeah because
that's my business yes so obviously you
will do the job yes yeah yeah it's very
simple there was a G20 big event in
Glasgow before one year yeah and uh
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi he
was coming there okay so this group just
went to welcome prime minister yes and
the higher level coach
okay so okay so you're basically saying
um so is this picture on your website no
now let me tell you yeah
do not forget we are from India yeah and
obviously Narendra Modi he is our prime
minister yeah so sorry when you you feel
happy that okay your coach is doing a
job for your prime minister because he
is coming and you are just taking people
there to welcoming them yeah obviously
you you feel happy so that's why I put
that picture on my Facebook account and
when I put the title yeah that we are
going to welcoming the uh prime minister
Indian Prime Minister that's it nothing
else okay I I understand from your point
of view it can be you know that's it
nothing else but see from a Muslims
point of view like for example if
let's give a Muslim country if a Muslim
country let's suppose I'm from Turkey so
if if in Turkey a my my president was
persecuting and killing
um not directly indirectly via you know
uh other means if that party was
involved in discrimination and uh
hostility towards certain groups be it
Christians uh be it Hindus be it seeks
um and then you need to understand that
I don't know if you're aware of what's
called in India I'm sure you are but how
would you feel if I for example my
company my coach company was involved in
this and then I put that picture because
what it does is in a nutshell it's as if
that I'm turning a blind eye to what's
happening so from your point of view do
you would you say at least like you
condemn like for example and what
they're doing not bgp or anything
if anyone is doing wrong with any human
matter is it a Muslim yes is it a Hindu
Christian or Punjabi yeah definitely I
am not with them okay anyone yes because
for me we all are brothers and sisters
yeah it's not about Hindu Muslim no I
don't believe in that yeah I run a tour
company and I welcome everyone
so many Muslim uh people yeah like a
brothers and they are my clients they
always choose only my company let me
tell if you read my itinerary Scotland
three days our first stop at Balaji
Temple
our first stop okay yeah I have so many
Muslim clients that choose our Scotland
tour and they come with us they come to
Balaji Temple okay okay no doubt they
sit inside the coach what they use
toilet facilities but they know
that they they look at me they don't
look at Temple or anything what they
think is no you think he will look after
us yeah our tour start Friday
now do not forget Friday's Juma yes am I
right yes jumma prayer is very important
yeah now whole day we are keep traveling
yeah whenever even I told them from
myself the brother don't worry I know
you need to do one prayer yes and we
always stop on Junction near Junction 33
Lancaster Services yeah why because
there is a prayer room
so our customer can do their prayers yes
this is all about respect yeah
personally I believe we should have a
respect for each and every religion
I I why we need to think you are Muslim
and you are Hindu no is it all our human
being yes second thing if if we are that
mentality then personally I think I
should be in India not here see this is
the country that's true where we we
shouldn't think in Hindu Muslim no we
all are those are sisters we are here to
look after our family and work hard yes
I think that should be everywhere but
the thing is that's true what you're
saying I agree with you that's that it
shouldn't be about Muslim Christian
that's what I'm saying but the BJP RSS
the Hindus they are doing exactly that
what you're saying they are doing the
Opposites which is like like you said we
shouldn't be doing this but that I can
understand your point of view yeah but
you need to just for my side what is I'm
thinking you need to understand one
thing
person like me yeah who is a business
man yeah yeah who is working hard to
feed his family yes
I have two sisters my family members
what depend on me yeah so my
concentration is on my business and my
family okay I don't want to go what BJP
is doing because they are big men see
when you are in trouble no one is coming
yeah you understand yes that's why I am
very far from everyone we have nothing
to do with and yes if something is doing
wrong then wrong is wrong so we will not
support them so would you cut them
bjprss when it comes to the treatment of
Muslims in India Sikhs and Christians if
they do wrong then definitely I will
condemn which there is evidence that
shows there so what I'm saying wrong is
wrong yes
wrong is wrong it's not about BJP or
anyone else or anything yes what I'm
saying is wrong is wrong definitely yes
so it's obviously like me like if you
said to me for example we had a couple
years ago Isis
you asked me I would say clearly it's
wrong what they are doing is wrong and
it should be condemned that's what I'm
supporting yes I am saying if there is a
wrong then definitely wrong why we
should support we don't personally we do
not support any wrong thing as you said
even my nature is same like you if my
parents is doing wrong I will not
support them yes I will also tell them
no this is wrong we shouldn't do this
yes so that's the I think what it is is
I think that's I think that's one of the
key things maybe playing the role
because I think what happened is
obviously you cleared that your coach
was not involved in that and you've
given me the trackers as well you sent
me I'll show you this evidence as well
which is clear that your coaches were
not involved and it's clear for what we
can see you know so I think we need to
be trusting that and not spread these
false rumors uh but I think what people
are upset about is obviously
um the coach being parked in front of
the temple and then I think that picture
with the BJP uh flag that was the news
that's why they made the correlation
definitely that's why I don't blame
anyone yeah see the way someone is
present the things yeah yeah and spoil
completely over image wrong way yeah
yes I request one thing to our people
all our Muslim brothers and sisters yes
Allah says
you can punish
who is culprit yeah if someone is wrong
obviously Allah will punish
but if someone is innocent yes and
without any proof yes
you keep calling and giving bad words
do you think
[Music]
that if I am innocent yeah yeah still
Allah will punish me no never see for
Allah we all are human beings yes
definitely Allah will see yes of course
that he is Hindu but he is innocent I
haven't done anything that's why that's
why I came here today so that's what my
request is yes that before you call
before you say anything please find out
the truth first exactly don't blame
anyone this is that and my request to
that person who may who made this video
yes only only that person who made these
videos yeah he made this video he did
viral he forget only one thing yeah on
day of judgment years
yeah yes when he will go to Allah yes on
the day of judgment yeah
I will be there
this is I will be standing there and I
will ask Allah that who gave him
permission yes to do this type of thing
for a family man who hasn't done
anything else so the problem that I'm
saying is Justice will be served because
I want to tell you one thing because
swear to God I have so many Muslim
friends yeah and
okay even they teach me when to say
inshallah and went to say masha'allah
see why because I respect that's why
they know yeah
since this thing happened yeah this
thing happened yeah they might be close
to Allah and you may not know how you
may be punished because of an accusation
by accusing what if you if you gain by
spreading a false tale about someone
Allah
says
your sign is that you don't speak to
people for three days
except through some signs point to the
child the child will speak on his own
Etc look at how silence is golden look
at how Silence has come to the rescue of
a person who was innocent sometimes my
brothers and sisters the accusations
against you might be so huge that only
Allah can clear your name don't worry
their patience take it in your stride
don't lose hope a day will come when you
will be smiling all the way Allah will
clear your name
now if you believe in this one yes
that's why you are here at my home
exactly I appreciate it Allah is
watching yes Irfan bye he helped me yeah
one of sister called yesterday yeah yeah
she tried to help me as well yeah today
you are here yes exactly
see no one can change your destiny if I
am punishable yeah yes you will not be
here yes definitely people will be here
with the stones yes to break my window
yes
exactly so so I I would say brother look
I I came here because at the end of the
day my religion teach me to be just if I
wanted I could be silent silent so you
can get so these rumors can carry on but
my religion teaches me that Justice I
don't care my differences towards you if
you was my enemy if I didn't like you if
I personally I was like me and your team
had a big problem we fight it but if
your name was tarnished I would still
come here today because the matter is
not about my issue between you it's
about Justice that Allah has told us to
live by we must we we must try to put
peace yes fighting is is not a solution
everyone should respect each everyone's
religious exactly everyone so what
message would you give to these young
Hindu like the Hindu like we've given a
message to the young Muslims as well but
to the Hindu the Hindu for group irises
the ones who went to Leicester I mean it
was uh they just turned up randomly when
things were coming down if they are
watching you what message would you give
them for the action that they've done
off you know some people were beaten
some were stabbed you know it was
unprovoked what message would you give
to your community for the youngsters who
are watching this I will always say that
never ever do anything uh which digital
piece second thing do not uh do not give
trouble to innocent people who have
nothing to do with anything yes
even March no this this all are not
solution
we are here to live peacefully enjoy the
life work hard look after our family
yeah and
forget about this Hindu Muslim and
everything no this is not the way to
live always Brotherhood should come
first yes
sir that's the way it should be thank
you I think that's it I think there's
not much that needs to be said brothers
and sisters
um all I can say is it also watching
this
um that's the angel tours or coaches
um they their coaches were not used for
this to say false information we have
seen the evidence
um and probably actually has made that
clear as well and also um people like
Muslim Community can be angry enough
said of course uh you know especially
you know when innocent people have been
attacked by certain mobs you know
belonging to the Hindu to RSS BJP group
but again it doesn't stop us from being
just and Justice is that so if he's
innocent I've come here to hear his
account and show you the evidence that
his coaches were not involved and like
he said he even you know refers to you
know Allah and Allah and Allah is just
Allah is just not towards just the
Muslims Allah has Justice towards even
if it's a non-muslim that's how Allah
Works brothers and sisters Justice is
important and one of the most things
that is just is for example says that
what are we told that you know we
worship Allah alone yeah so we
inherently have to know and be better
when it comes to Justice and not spread
false information if you see something
you can't think oh this there so there
was a picture here even if there is yes
I understand bjb picture and the Hindu
temple and his coach still there is not
evidence for you to come and say this
connects here that connects there's
always connected here we cannot really
say that so that's it that's what I want
to say I want to say function probably a
team for inviting me to your house thank
you and I really appreciate it thank you
um and please share this video so this
masturbation is not spread anymore till
next time